don't worry about your good yeah is
changed
are you guys still torrid your is that
you guys still tour yeah yeah we're
still a band Jane's Addiction Wow don't
get offended I don't know I was trying
to be enthusiastic that was an offense
that was enthusiasm yeah yeah Brian
I mean you we come out and play Jane's
hasn't gone you guys have so many good
dude we now we're still a band it's been
like our nothing shocking our first
record came out thirty years ago I mean
girls younger than the records I've made
right it's always a prerequisite when I
meet a garlic have you ever rewound
anything what are you doing Friday yeah
we want because what girls now like kids
now don't they don't know what rewinding
is yeah but what Jesus diction came out
they'd had CDs no yeah yeah yeah yeah
tapes - I'm just saying yeah I just I'm
saying that that's my dating cutoff if
you remember when microwaves came out
it's not happy actually I've been going
VHS is a good car off okay beta my do
you remember Betamax yes I have actually
a Betamax still but I remember them only
because I grew up in the Philippines we
were a little behind and talking in
technology oh yeah yeah well I I I used
to I use I don't know why but I always
went for I had this this this
characteristic in me that I'm sure you
can relate to you put a sea of beautiful
women in front of me I will pick out the
one that has the most problematic
insights no matter what yeah they could
all look identical but the one that's
most crazy that's the one I'm gonna pick
that's the one for me and so it's in
it's usually IIIi would find so I'm just
over that drama
so like lately I've been dating a little
bit more in my age range oh cool and
it's uh
I feel like you'd be really
well matched up with like a nerdy girl
like a nerdy hot girl I think so too
right right guy like yeah yeah if she's
intellectually kind of you know and then
if the fact and if I haven't had sex
with her yet I will definitely be
interested yeah the stuff about you that
is what you're interesting guy what is
the quality I look for yeah what is it
with the ability to turn into other
women you don't get bored yeah honey put
this really how long have you been
together we have to be different he has
to be like the Japanese businessman
anymore I can't show up as kalila
anymore okay that's interesting you may
at work I've I've never dated anyone
that as long this is double the time
yeah actually I don't know that you and
I am apps I can't believe I found her
that's been great how did you guys meet
tinder tinder you're kidding tinder yeah
when tinder first started there was
still some talent there
I tried it once and I tried Brian tell
us about Riya because none of us have
ever the only person that I met on Riya
and went out with was an ex-girlfriend
matched up again we're like oh this is
really Wow
let's get together anyway but that's the
only time I didn't I didn't I just don't
like I don't know I just I'm more old
school in the sense that if I see a girl
at a Starbucks or Erewhon or whatevs
walked our line the hottest people in
the world are hot hipsters yeah it's
just it's have you been there lately
yeah but you got your one minute you can
shop with me brother I would love the
corner shop where we apple cider vinegar
oh that's good
good talking about it sir probiotics you
likes probiotic talking about probiotics
and kale and [ __ ] do you date women
though that don't know who you are now
I'm sure I don't care about [ __ ] up they
now but they all know I don't yeah but
I'm really I'm so amesh in my
professional life that's the last thing
I want to do or talk about or be yeah
when I'm on my own time you know yeah
like it's just it's enough you know what
I mean it's like it's enough for me
already yeah yeah it's really difficult
because my dates will think that I'm
like withholding stuff about myself but
I just don't want to [ __ ] talk about
I'm over it I'm bored of it you mean I
won't hear about you I don't know it's
weird but yeah I guess I guess there's
some preconceived notions I mean it
makes it harder and it makes it easier I
guess you know yeah sometimes it's
easier to meet people but sometimes it's
harder because they assume that I expect
X Y & Z you know
[Music]